في اضنه وجدنا العديد من القصص التي
التقينا باشخاص عاشوا هذه اللحظات لحظات
الصفر للزلزال وهم ايضا سعوديون التقيناهم
في هذه المنطقه وكانوا متواجدون في تلك
المنطقه والاعلنا ناخذ بعض هذه اللحظات
التي عاشها الاستاذ حمدان الشمري وهو كان
متواجد في منطقه بالقرب او بقرب حدثنا
حمدان عن لحظات الصفر التي عشتها وانت
الان بعيد ومنزلك ايضا
اعتقد قلت لي انه تهدم بالكامل بسم الله
والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله اشكر قناه
العربيه على استضافتي الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله انا تقريبا الساعه
4:14 كنت نيم بفراشي
جتني هزه ارضيه مع انه قبل 14 يوم حصلت
هزه خفيفه وعاديه شوي
الكبته والدولاب طاح قدامي اول ما طاح
حملت نفسي وطلعت نزلت مع الدرج بسرعه
وارتباك وكانت في احجار تطيح عليه
اضربي يمين ويسار
وزي الحلم يعني انا ما اول مره اعيش
التجربه فطلعت في الدور الخامس وما كان في
الاسانسير ما كان شغال مصعد ونزلت الحمد
لله اخر ثانيه انا طلعت المدخل
المجمع اللي ساكن فيه طاح طلعت برا الناس
مرعوبه الناس ناس تصيح وناس يعني لا يعلم
الله لا يعلم الا الله بحالهم طلعت برا
وجلست تقريبا من الساعه اربعه وربع الين
الساعه 8:00 الصبح
بالبرد ماني لابس الا شيء خفيف ولا اني
عارف شو بيصير والناس جالسه تحذر انشقاقات
بالارض اصوات طلعنا الظهر الحمد لله بعد
صارت هزه ثانيه واخف من اللي قبل
وجلست الين ما جت الساعه تقريبا الين
الليل عشت في الحديقه انا مع الاخوان
التركيه في العراق حمدان كل هذا في العراق
يعني لاني لابس شيء ولا في اي مساعدات ولا
في احد قدر يوصل لنا بسبب الزلزال فجلست
الليله الثانيه مع الاخوان الاتراك في
الحدائق اي والله طبعا مطر وبرد وحاله ما
يعلم بالله الله انزل تهدم ما نزل تهدم
والمنازل البقيه وهذا في بيت قابل للسكن
يعني كامل المنطقه وحذرون انه ما احد يطلع
للبيت خلوكم في الحدائب جلسنا بالحدائق
الين ثاني يوم ثاني يوم الحمد لله تواصلت
مع السفاره
وتواصلت مع محمد الحربي اي والله قال لي
تجيني بمكان التجمع اي والله جيت والحمد
لله ما قصروا وبيض الله وجيههم وبيض الله
وجيه حكومه خادم الحرمين الشريفين على
استضافتي وقاموا بعمل واجبي وانساني
والحمد لله جيت هنا وشفت النعمه وشفت
الراحه وشفت الطمانينه والوضع مستتم الحمد
لله على السلامه الحمد لله على
ميسون هذا كما تشاهدين حمدان هو واحد من
القصص لعدد من السعوديين الذين تم اجلائهم
من المناطق تحدثت عن 45 سعودي تم اجلائهم
للمناطق التي ضربها هذا الزلزال بالاضافه
الى تواجد ايضا بلاغ عن سيده سعوديه
متواجده في احد المباني التي انهدمت بشكل
كامل وهنالك تنسيق بين السلطات السعوديه
والتركيه حيال هذه السيده التي لم يتم
تاكيد حتى الان عن مدى
مدى تواجدها في هذا المكان او حتى عمليه
اج لائها